[Music]
we are following dramatic new
developments in the case of a missing
Connecticut mother of five children
Jennifer doulos her estranged husband
Fotis doulos was charged with murder and
kidnapping yesterday and taken into
police custody he is expected to be
arraigned later today two other people
were arrested in connection with
Jennifer's death molla leg is outside
the state courthouse in Stanford with
more on this story
Moeller the arrest warrants revealed
very stunning details please share yes
right gale good morning authorities
believe that foetus Doulos killed
Jennifer Doulos his wife the day that
she disappeared and then recruited his
then girlfriend Michelle true CONUS to
help him clean up authorities say that
trakone Asst told them that she that
foetus doulos often told her that
sometimes he hoped Jennifer disappeared
police swarmed foetus doulos Connecticut
mansion Tuesday taking the 52 year-old
away in handcuffs on charges of murder
and kidnapping norm pattice is his
attorney we welcome this fight because
we think we will win it police believe
Doulos killed his estranged wife
Jennifer at her home the morning of May
24th a friend reported her missing after
she didn't show up to an appointment
police say they have surveillance video
showing doulas and his ex-girlfriend
Michele truck Onis dumping evidence
later that day according to a newly
released arrest warrant police say they
found a garbage bag which tested
positive for the DNA of foetus and
Jennifer doulos as well as truck Onis
inside it were zip ties investigators
believe doulos used to restrain Jennifer
they also allegedly found other items
like a sponge mop handle and a black
garden glove her body has not been found
Andrew Bauman is trakone is's lawyer she
has always been extremely cooperative
and you know we'll have to deal with
these charges in court
authorities say true CONUS was not
truthful in police interviews and
frequently changed her story a friend of
foetus is also now implicated on a
conspiracy charge a 6-foot hole
discovered on property connected to Kent
Melanie was described by one person who
found it as 100% a human grave
investigators found no evidence of
remains cell phone records allegedly
show Melanie had contact with foetus the
day Jennifer disappeared in his arrest
warrant police say in interviews with
him he was frequently vague or evasive
at times self contradictory meanwhile
Doulos his attorney cast doubt Tuesday
on whether Jennifer is really even dead
I don't know whether she's dead or alive
there's circumstantial evidence that she
may well be dead
I've got to see the quantity of that
Jennifer doula says family says they're
relieved by the arrests but they bring
no sense of closure nothing can bring
Jennifer back they say authorities have
not released a motive in Jennifer's
murder but they do point out in the
arrest warrants that foetus doulos is
millions of dollars in debt do Llosa's
attorney as well as Jennifer Michele
trakone is's attorney both point out and
insist that their clients are innocent
Tony I'm Ola thank you very much you
know the day she disappeared she just
dropped her kids off at school I
remember that Smola still with us
because I'm curious about this happened
seven months ago molla does the arrest
warrant indicate why it took so long to
make an arrest
right the arrest warrant does not gale
and authorities did not take any
questions yesterday because they're
under a gag order from another similar
another trial another case pending
against foetus too low so they have
really not answered any questions with
regards to why this took so long to
bring charges attorneys for both doulos
as well as Turk Onis both also did not
answer those questions and they say that
they hope authorities have some good
evidence because it took so long to
bring out these charges for it one
factor is a thank you
you